Now I'd like to talk about a topic that is sometimes confusing for students,
and that is the topic of statistical significance. Statistical significance in
the area of statistics has a very specialized meaning. It's kind of
counterintuitive. It doesn't really fit what we normally think of in terms of
significance. So, in everyday life, we use the word significant to talk about
things that are important to us, things that are large or sizable, things that
are meaningful. In statistics, the phrase statistical significance has none of
these meanings. I'm going to write on the other side what significance does
mean. Significance does mean that we've rejected the null hypothesis.
Significance also means that our results are not likely due to chance or
sampling error. Notice that this and this are just two different ways of saying
the same thing. The important point is to know when you see the words
statistical significance, it doesn't mean that our results were important. That
they were large or sizable or that they were even meaningful. All it means is
that the results are probably not due to chance. In other words, we've ruled
random chance at or sampling error as an explanation of our results. That's an
important point to keep in mind. So how do we know if the results of a research
study were meaningful or important? One thing we have to know is what was
measured? What were the variables? Did the variables have practical or social
importance or even theoretical importance? Obviously, if our variables do not
have any importance in terms of practical application, social issues, or
theory, then clearly, it doesn't matter what the results were, the results are
not important. Another thing to consider in assessing the meaningfulness of
results is the effect size. How large were the results? That doesn't meant that
small results are not important or that large results are necessarily
important. But effect size is considered when assessing the meaningfulness of
results. And it's possible for even very small effect sizes to be very
important. A final thing to consider is can we rule out random chance for the
results? In other words, can we rule out sampling error as an explanation? Now,
this doesn't guarantee that our results are important, but it goes along way to
helping us asses the rest of the import. Next, we need to know can we rule out
alternative explanations for the results? These are those dreaded lurking
variables we've been talking about before. So putting this all together, this
gives you a rough guideline of assessing whether the results of a study are
meaningful. What was measured, how large was the effect, could we rule out
random chance as an explanation, and can we rule out lurking variables as an
explanation for the results?